Tetris that's the perfect game I'm gonna
go to Moscow securing worldwide handheld
rights
they're still considers America enemy
Numero Uno if you go we can't protect
you
okie dokie
the movie is an extraordinary ordinary
stories set in Soviet Russia in 1999
about different people from all over the
world pursuing this incredibly hot
property my character Hank is a kind of
Larger than Life Cowboy figure goes out
on a limb to make his fortune and get
the rights to Tetris when I first found
Tetris I was a publisher of computer
games in Japan the people who were
publishing had no idea what they had
they got the console rights in Japan and
then Game Boy came up gentlemen if you
want to sell a couple hundred thousand
game boys to little kids package them
with Mario but if you want to sell
millions of game boys
packaging with Tetris I made a deal with
the president of Nintendo USA a month
later I was on a plane to Moscow to get
the Game Boy rights
we're in a room full of eight business
people there are definitely some KGB
guys in the room you can go home today
will you stay and face the consequences
but like see pause at Northland I first
met in that room I used the original
creator of Tetris tank was the first man
Alexis can talk about computers too well
actually your game is brilliant I'm
Gonna Make You A Millionaire I do not
have right to receive money from my game
well that that's criminal no
it is communism Tetris is made by an
achievement in my life that was the only
Russian software coming out of Soviet
Union that time
there's lots of corruption there and
people after money and there's this one
man who's made this thing that everyone
wants we'll start by licensing computer
games then video games arcade games
board games everything
but it's this Mad Dash
to secure
the rights to the game
get me Tetris
don't sacrifice everything for these
we were living in this two-bedroom
apartment supporting this crazy
Foreigner father it was really a
transformational time in our family's
lives everything is going to be fine
because if it isn't then we don't have
handheld rights and we don't have
console rights and Nintendo will sue us
for fraud and we'll lose the business
and they'll probably take our house and
I am trying to keep it together it can
be really I am but I do not have a
backup plan
it's strange watching somebody else be
me it was fun to watch because he does a
good job
I was impressed at the script and now
the actors as well they really captured
what the real people were like
personally for my part I always just
feel if you seek to humanize somebody
and make them relatable and
three-dimensional than you are doing
them the right service sorry hon Papa's
gotta go and get ready for his business
trip
but I can't wait to see your show
Tetris process boundaries you know it
brings people of all cultures together
Hank and Alexi they're incredibly
different in terms of their family lives
but they love programming
partners are what make us great not only
is Tetris an amazing game but it was
only possible through this friendship
between Hank and Alexi that it spread
through the rest of the world he's the
author of Pittsburgh
is my friends
when you take a photo how do you make
the photo have the same emotional impact
as when you were actually there
I think the movie does that very well
[Music]